[Music]
eric's in san antonio hey eric your
question for uh mr success magazine and
me
all right thank you dave and anthony
thanks for taking my call i really
appreciate it
sure what's up i'm i'm 38 years old
and i'm married uh with no kid um
we are on baby step six but the catch is
well we currently rent and we've
actually been renting for
for about seven years now in the san
antonio area
and uh the reason why is because he only
thought to be here for
a short period of time because it's
relocating for my job
uh but it turns out everyone's remote
now i made a series of steps a series of
moves
that have been uh pretty lucrative and i
think we're probably gonna be sticking
around here for the next five to ten
years
um so we've actually been looking for a
home good and um
we're in an option period right now i
actually put a cash offer on a home
and uh i'm really we're both very very
nervous about this we've never been
homeowners before
and one to kind of get your opinion i'm
just kind of wondering how much
of our total net worth should lie in the
home's value
we do have enough cash to actually buy a
house outright
but um that's impressive i don't know
we're not uh we're all nervous about
renting just
or buying how much how much are you how
much you're spending
350 000. i love it where'd it go stud
i love it i love it how much do you make
a year eric
uh together we make 366 thousand dollars
a year
yeah yeah
buy the house
and we're not laughing at you no we're
just laughing it's just i understand
listen you make 350 you have 350 you're
going to spend 350 on a house
that's going to go up in value and pay
cash and have no mortgage
there is nothing here in this equation
to even be remotely nervous about
nothing what is the worst case scenario
yeah
let's just pretend you forget to put
fire insurance on it and it burns down
okay and so you lose 350 thousand
dollars this is your worst case scenario
yeah
and that that would like put you in the
stupid column because you didn't put
fire insurance on it right so
um but you're going to do that but i
mean i mean what can go wrong with this
with this plan
it's just the idea of paying out of
pocket for i mean for maintenance
and uh it's all new that's all okay so
how much is your rent
1400 a month okay so there's fifteen
thousand
eighteen thousand dollars a year yeah
for maintenance
yep because you don't have that payment
anymore
right right but then i mean it's just i
i only know from what friends and family
have told us about home ownership
it does cost money and it does it is a
pain in the butt to keep them maintained
it's part of the thing it's part of the
dirty little secret of home ownership
yes but you make 350 000 a year you
don't have any payments
i think you can pull it off yeah and
here's a good thing too you know like
dave said i mean i'm a homeowner young
guy like yourself just purchased my home
and uh your second one my second one
yeah actually my second one
um and here's here's what i recommend
you're gonna build it you're gonna get
that first year
be very strict with that first year
warranty with your builder make sure
they do
are you building are you paying cash for
an existing paying cash for an existing
asset oh yeah yeah okay yeah and i have
and there wasn't telling me to get
to insure make sure i get a home
warranty no no
yeah no this is a brand new build or is
it like already used
it's already used i don't buy extended
warranties you just self-insure get a
good home inspection and make sure
that your mechanicals are up to date and
operating and that you're not got
something that's on its last leg like a
heating and air system that's eight
grand or something
but other than that dude just you
self-insure through that stuff you don't
buy insurance on
uh extended warranties on houses and no
man you've done so good
yes this is not time to be nervous it's
time to celebrate yeah yeah
i appreciate that everything right yeah
impressive very is that helpful
yes it is thanks a lot i appreciate that
yeah you're doing great i mean if you
told me you're buying a million dollar
house and
you know you're paying cash oh by the
way i'll go back and answer your
question what percentage of your
net worth i would look at two things i
would look at net worth
and i would look at your income uh if
you're paying cash for it
it could be whatever percentage you want
it to be typically what we find eric is
the more wealthy people become
the smaller percentage their home is of
their net worth
i will tell you that in our study of
millionaires that the typical
millionaire uh would have about a
million and a half net worth as an
example and they'd have
like have 500k in the house and about a
million in their 401k we saw that with
hogan's
city a bunch right but if you get to
somebody that's got 40 million
you don't usually see one-third of their
net worth tied up in a house it starts
to scale down
yes you know they might have a five
million dollar house or a four million
dollar house
so it might be ten percent rather than
thirty percent of your net worth so the
higher your net worth
the smaller percentage normally is in
your home
right if it's not it says that that home
is
probably a little too important to you
for maybe the wrong reasons
right now i've got a big nice house but
it is a
very small percentage of my net worth
yes this is not a small house but it is
a small
percentage yeah i said i have my big ass
yeah big nice
but if i had that house and it was a
large because it's kind of a statement
house yeah it's like a
too big it is and so but if i had that
house and it was like
90 of my net worth that says dave's more
worried about what other people think
yeah that's what that would say yes so
that's kind of you look at it that way
you're you're in a great shape here dude
you're in great shape
so proud of you